mein thema heute abend ist eine
erschreckende nachricht keine eu
volkswirtschaft und hier muss man es
keine wirklich betont wird in diesem
jahr weniger stark wachsen als die
deutsche wird deutschland zum kranken
mann europas gut möglich und kein wunder
krieg energiekrise pandemie lieferketten
probleme die deutschen unternehmen
kämpfen gerade mit vielen problemen es
ist nicht übertrieben ist die
grundsätzliche frage zu stellen ist das
über jahrzehnte so erfolgreiche
wirtschaftsmodell made in germany am
ende und die frage würde ich gerne als
erst als sie stellen wie würden sie das
einschätzen die aktuelle wirtschaftslage
in deutschland naja die deutsche
wirtschaft hat ein spezielles modell das
mitteleuropäische modell beruht darauf
dass im mittelstand haben das machen
auch die schweizer so auch die polen die
tschechen das ist hier über jahrhunderte
so gewachsen aus den zünften und wenn
sie mal angucken deutschland bin kriegt
ungefähr die hälfte seiner
staatseinnahmen über die firmen die im
export tätig sind oder dienstleistung
zum export machen das heißt sie sind
exportabhängigen holen weil er aber
stolz darauf export weil ja inzwischen
überholt wurden von den chinesen aber
der punkt auf den ich hinaus will ist
eigentlich wir sind eine stark
mittelständisch geprägte wirtschaft und
wir sind ein stark export geprägte
wirtschaft das sind die zwei wichtigsten
faktoren die jetzt eine rolle spielen
wenn der export schlechter und
schwieriger würde das wird er aus
verschiedenen gründen kann nicht gleich
aufzählen dann haben wir ein
einnahmeproblem auf dauer das muss man
erst mal feststellen und die
mittelständler die haben jetzt die
situation dass bei den meisten drei
daumenschrauben nebeneinander angezeigt
werden die erste ist die lohnfindung und
gehälter findung durch den mindestlohn
angeheizt und die inflation geht also
aufwärts muss es bezahlen die zweite
zwinge ist sozusagen rohstoffe und
vorprodukte plastik schränke
schaltschränke keine ahnung was da jeder
braucht das muss erst mal alles besorgt
werden ist zum teil teurer geworden gibt
es gerade nicht und die dritte zwinger
ist natürlich der energiepreis und es
hat unternehmer angerufen sagte hermenau
ich weiß nicht mehr weiter ich kriege
keine stromversorgung vertrat fürs
nächste jahr ich kann keine kalkulation
machen einer die intensive branche was
soll das werden die unternehmer sind gar
nicht in der lage sich auf die krise
einzustellen weil sie die krise gar
nicht einschätzen können und niemand
scheint sie einschätzen zu können und
das ist ein problem das ist von erster
ordnung weil es wird bedeuten dass dann
eine schleifspur bei den steuereinnahmen
den nächsten jahren einsetzt manche
unternehmer werden die produktion
runterfahren es kann sein dass es
steigende arbeitslosenzahlen gibt es
weit über 5 die schon mal als hoch
eingeschätzt worden sind die lage ist
nicht einfach es ist ja schon passiert
das erste unternehmen produktions lauf
bei leise produktionsstätten geschlossen
haben weil es sich nicht mehr rentiert
sie haben gerade auch angesprochen mit
der arbeitslosigkeit genug sehen sie
denn da die gefahr na ja wir können gut
und gerne 5 6 millionen arbeitslose
kriegen alleine durch die energie
sprünge also es ist ja auch schwierig
zum beispiel nur metallproduktion da
können sie nicht einfach mal ein
stromausfall machen
willst ihm dann ist ihre schmelze sachen
im eimer dann ist meistens auch ihr ofen
im eimer sie müssen dann also völlig
noch mal alles auf kacheln usw es gibt
richtig verwerfungen der glasbläserei
kann man nicht einfach mal wir haben es
gerade mal keine energie das geht so
nicht in der von der mikrochips rede ich
gar nicht erst also es gibt viele
branche die darauf angewiesen sind dass
der energiefluss stetig schließt die
könne nicht einfach ab und abschalten
und wir haben ja auch bei den kraftwerks
versorgung große probleme weil wir gar
nicht mehr so viele kraftwerke haben die
nicht in schwarz statt hinkriegen also
die aus dem nichts heraus sozusagen
wieder energie produzieren die meisten
brauchen januar zum funken - zündkerze
heute das ist unübersichtlich also die
können nicht alle produzieren die bäcker
werden sagen wenn mein ofen kalt es gibt
keine brötchen also das geht dann mit
viel bereiche wir haben die situation
mit dem stoff auch der erdöl einfuhren
zumindest über die trasse und damit nach
später nach leuna das bedeutet im osten
bei schwedt benzin und kerosin
verknappung und das bedeutet über leuna
plastik wird nicht hergestellt wenn das
öl nicht da ist dann können sie die
ganzen plastikprodukte nicht herstellen
ich will sich ab jetzt alle den joghurt
in heimkehrern durch die gegend tragen
wollen oder müssen das irgendwie zu
lösungen kommen wenn wir das einschätzen
wird deutschland zum kranken mann
europas ich habe gerade das gefühl dass
wir im letzten unbeschwerten sommer sind
vor der ganz großen krise die beiden
vergangenen sommer auch die waren ja
schon nicht ganz ohne wenn man ein
crooner zurückdenkt aber ich glaube
corona wird uns vorkommen wie er so als
hätte es im prinzip keine probleme
gegeben denn wenn die krise erst mal
richtig los geht das heißt wirklich
dauerhaft die energieprobleme das heißt
inflation die entweder weiter steigt
oder auf diesem hohen niveau bleibt
womöglich politische verwerfungen kommen
womöglich eine neue eurokrise und
arbeitslosigkeit dazu ich glaube dann
geht es wirklich rund in deutschland
deswegen mir kommt das so vor wenn nicht
so durchs berlin durch schöne abend
berlin spazieren die menschen im café
sehr ich glaube da kommt was auf uns zu
was wir noch gar nicht absehen können
nächstes jahr wird das einfach nicht
mehr so unbeschwert wie es jetzt gerade
auf der anderen seite kommt dann über
wir sprechen von arbeitslosigkeit und
steigender arbeitslosigkeit würde ich
jeden tag uns fehlen fachkräfte es
werden programme entwickelt wie kriegen
wir fachkräfte nach deutschland damit
vor allem der mittelstand
handwerksbetriebe und um überhaupt
arbeiten können mit leuten also das
beißt sich eigentlich aber erhöht
eigentlich nur die katastrophe das
problem ist dass die die freigesetzt
werden nicht unbedingt die fachkräfte
der zimmer sie müssen um gelernt werden
es kann auch sein wir haben uns das
weiter bei der autoproduktion gesehen da
werden sehr gut geschulte fachkräfte
dann entlassen zum beispiel aber diese
fallen eben auch als hochwertige
steuerzahler weg dann stimmt diese
rechnung wieder nicht mehr wir haben
auch eine menge leute die arbeitslos
sind aber die von ihrer qualifikationen
nicht in die anspruchs profile beim
mittelstand passen der mittelstand hat
der kein fließband da musste schon ein
bisschen mehr können das wirklich eine
wichtige frage und dann höre ich jeden
tag in der kneipe wir haben kein
personal im hotel das muss kein personal
ja dann haben
bilder mit hunderten von lastwägen
eigentlich fahren weil es keine fahrer
gibt und und und und dann frage ich mich
wenn überall leute die sind woanders hin
in der pandemie höhe sind woanders sind
die woanders sind wo sind die denn wenn
alle klagen über den mars stimmen also
ich wollte noch mal sagen ich finde so
diese ich sag mal so endzeit szenarien
ist alles ganz furchtbar und schlimmer
ich glaube auch das ist sicherlich nicht
nicht leichter wird aber das finde ich
immer finde ich keine gute einstellung
also ich glaube schon dass die zukunft
ist ja noch nicht geschrieben sondern
ich sag mal so was nächsten sommer
passiert steht ja was sie sagen oder was
auch du gesagt hast weil die das kann
ich super nachvollziehen aber am ende
muss man sagen haben wir haben wir immer
noch alle möglichkeiten ich finde und
das sage jetzt einfach mal aus einem der
quasi aus dem volk ist ich bin in meinem
club ich spiele fußball ich habe das
gefühl dass wir uns in deutschland wir
kümmern uns um jeden auf der welt wir
wollen alles wir wollen das klima ändern
wir wollen alles in ordnung wir kümmern
die ukraine alles super nur das einzige
was unsere politik immer vergisst ist
einfach mal sich um unsere leute zu
kommen sie zu kümmern dass die hier zu
hause sind ja hier wohnen weil das ist
das fundament von allem und ich kenne
das aus dem flugzeug wenn der druck
abfällt dann soll man sich vor allem
erst mal selber die maske aufsetzen weil
wenn man die nie auf setzt dann kann man
den anderen eben mehr helfen und ich
finde das wäre etwas was ich mir von der
politik wünschen würde vielleicht mal
den fokus bei 23 themen ein bisschen 20
jahren ganz konkrete forderungen also
wird sie jetzt sagen das wäre gut wenn
es jetzt passieren in deutschland wir
haben wir das heute noch als thema und
wenn ich glaube man wenn man den
menschen wie will man den menschen
erklären dass man 100 milliarden ausgibt
für irgendwelche panzer wo gaga weiß wie
die aussichten für was sie am ende
genutzt werden und für die eigenen
menschen die einer flutkatastrophe zum
opfer gefallen sind und ich habe auch
beim menschen kennen gelernt die dort
wirklich haus und hof und alles möglich
verloren haben und die warten dann
gefühlt also ich gebe das nur weiter was
man mir erzählt hat die warten dann auf
gelder und sagen wir warten jetzt schon
seit einem halben jahr ich glaube ein
jahr ist es jetzt her und haben immer
noch nichts bekommen hier kann man doch
keinen erklären und dann muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen also erstmal erwarte ich
dass man den menschen einfach hilft
finde ich und das wird auch werden auch
die meisten liga zu schauen so sehen und
wenn man es dann anders macht ja dann
muss man es vielleicht auch ein bisschen
geschickter erklären also würde ich nein
da muss man aber wissen da muss man
zumindest mal ein bisschen geschickter
verkaufen weil sonst sagt ja jeder so
tut mir leid aber das finde ich
toll wird den menschen nicht geholfen
aber frau bär book unsere
aussenministerin hat eben eine südsee
beauftragte einberufen
es gibt 42 bundesbeauftragte für alles
auf also für dinge die ich im traum
nicht gekommen wäre aber der
bundeskanzler ist vereidigt darauf dem
deutschen volk gutes zu tun ich habe
einen schaden abzuwenden haben sie schon
einen lieblings beauftragten
harald martenstein ein bekannter
journalist und kolumnist hat in der welt
in diesem hause erscheint zum letzten
kolumne und hat sich darüber ausgelassen
wird 42 bundesbeauftragte und hat mich
vorgeschlagen mit der bemerkung ich sei
der richtige mann als weißbier bundes
[Gelächter]
viele bundesbürger würden das
unterstützen ich glaube auch aber ich
hätte noch ein paar andere aufgabe er
hatte ich kann weil ich nämlich auch der
meinung in deutschland glaubt immer oder
die politik zumindest ein großteil als
rettungswagen in dieser welt unterwegs
auf mission unterwegs zu sein beifahrer
ja und meine frau matze kennt petra die
sagt auch sag mal die sind doch
eigentlich für uns gewählt die sind doch
von uns für uns gewesen die sogar zu
diese bundes beauftragen habe ich
gelesen jährigen 10.000 euro im monat
mal 42 ich bin kein bin kein mensch der
neid hat aber eine rechnung darf man der
trotzdem aufmachen muss das wirklich
sein und wird das lächeln und sie denn
politiker zahlen vielmehr also jetzt
verdienen weil dann wären sie nicht
korrumpierbar oder weniger korrumpierbar
ich bin der meinung also wenn der
bundeskanzler weniger verdient als sie
intendantin von einer ard-anstalt rbb
die verdient jetzt 310.000 euro ob sie
sie verdient weiß ich nichts sie kriegt
sie auf jeden fall
und die bundeskanzlerin um 250 oder
260.000 nicht informiert bin keine 300
olaf scholz verdient jetzt mehr als
300.000 ich glaube wir hatten kürzlich
berichtet dass es jetzt hätte mit 30.000
im monat sind da hätte man ihn belastet
ihn vielleicht aber ich hätte mich auch
die wunder dass sie sich gleich für sich
sorgen
wobei ich wobei ich mich an franz josef
strauß erinnerte der mal gesagt hat wer
glaubt dass die sozis etwas und geld
verstehen glaubt auch dass ich ein hund
einen wurstvorrat und legt wir sind bei
einem thema das werk geld ich bin zum
beispiel für diese 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr weil sonst wäre die nur
zum feuerlöschen und zum brunnen bauen
da wir müssen wir müssen angesichts der
bedrohung aus dem osten die es gibt eine
bundeswehr haben die funktioniert